[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
covering a topic that has been requested
a lot in the comments section
i had made a video on this topic
previously but that was near the
beginning of the channel
and i didn't do a very good job of it so
now i'm here for redemption
the subject of today's video is how did
the motherly
nurturing and caring molly weasley
defeat the powerful
infamous and feared bellatrix the
strange
amidst the total chaos of the battle of
hogwarts there were many
iconic moments but there was one in
particular that stuck out to me
as it put the power of love on display
in totality
jets of light flew left and right and
witches and wizards fought
all over the place but in one area of
the castle there was a showdown that
meant everything for one person
that person was molly weasley the caring
tender mother of the weasley family
and standing mother for harry potter had
found herself battling
with one of the most feared witches in
the wizarding world bellatrix the
strange
bellatrix's fear-inspiring name and
bloodthirsty reputation
were well deserved and she was known to
have murdered and tortured numerous
witches and wizards
including neville longbottom's parents
her magical capabilities were more than
impressive
and she was widely considered to be one
of the most powerful and dangerous
witches
of her time bellatrix was also one of if
not
voldemort's most loyal follower as well
as his most
powerful follower after snape however
snape wasn't a genuine follower
she was a frightening pureblood witch
that came from the black family
a long line of powerful witches and
wizards with the twisted agenda
she was personally responsible for
murdering sirius black
and in fedora tonks and she showcased an
affinity for the cruciatus curse
and displayed considerable knowledge in
the realm of the dark arts
not only that but she was also an expert
duelist
charms expert powerful oklahomans and
tenacious warrior
molly weasley was well molly weasley a
motherly
figure known for her love and her
ability to nurture and care
for those that she was close to she was
never stated to possess
any sort of insane magical power but
what she did have was an edge
a side of her that didn't come out very
often this edge of course only came out
when those that she loved were in danger
and in the battle of hogwarts bellatrix
and this other side of molly were
introduced
to set the scene bellatrix was first
fighting hermione luna and ginny
the three young witches collaborating
together were equalizing with bellatrix
but when bellatrix shot a killing curse
that was so close to ginny that she
missed death by an inch
molly had to step in she had had enough
let's explore the text further not my
daughter you
yelled molly mrs weasley threw off her
cloak as she ran
freeing her arms bellatrix spun on the
spot
roaring with laughter the sight of her
new challenger out of my way
shouted mrs weasley to the three girls
and with the swipe of her wand she began
to jewel
harry watched with terror and elation as
molly weasley's one slashed and twisted
and bellatrix the strange's smile
faltered and became a snarl
jets of light flew from both ones the
floor around the witch's feet became hot
and cracked
both women were fighting to kill what
will happen to your children when i've
killed you
taunted bellatrix as mad as her master
capering as molly's curse is danced
around her
when mommy's gone the same way as
freddie you will never
touch up children again screamed mrs
weasley
bellatrix laughed the same exhilarated
laugh her cousin sirius had given
as he toppled backward through the veil
and suddenly harry knew what was going
to happen
before it did molly's curse sawed
beneath bellatrix's outstretched arm
and hit her squarely in the chest
directly over her heart
bellatrix's gloating smile froze her
eyes began to bulge
for the tiny space of time she knew what
had happened
and then she toppled and the watching
crowd roared and voldemort
screamed and just like that molly
weasley defeated the infamous bellatrix
the strange
but other than being on the receiving
end of a curse what actually caused
bellatrix to die
what curse did molly use in the film why
did bellatrix
explode we all know that avada kadavra
is the killing curse
and that it would be the obvious spell
choice that one might use when wanting
to
kill someone but the text doesn't ever
indicate that this is the spell that she
used
in the books when someone uses avada
kadavra it almost always describes it as
a green jet of light
and in this instance it just wasn't the
case to further argue that it wasn't
avada cadaver that she used
we need to remember that vada kedavra is
one of the unforgivable curses
not only is the use of these curses
punishable but their mere existence is
frowned upon
by regular witches and wizards molly
just simply wouldn't have used it
even in these dire dire circumstances as
i feel that by using it
she may feel that she is stooping to
level the bad guys
additionally avada kedavra just doesn't
fit here
so if we're pretty sure she didn't use
avada kadavra how did bellatrix actually
die how else could molly have killed her
this
is where we need to dissect the text a
little molly's curse sword beneath
bellatrix's
outstretched arm and hit her squarely in
the chest directly over her heart
if it wasn't a lethal spell that molly
used then to me it would suggest that
the placement of the spell
was the leading factor in bellatrix's
death stunning spells are popular among
witches and wizards
and in my eyes there are two possible
non-murderous spells
that molly could have used the less
likely spell being a well-positioned
petrificus totalis
petroficus totalis is also known as the
full-body bind curse
and essentially freezes paralyzes your
enemy
my thought process here is that because
the spell hit bellatrix directly above
her heart
it could have frozen her heart and
stopped from pumping blood
effectively killing her and while this
does check out for the most part
i feel that it is more likely that molly
used stupefy
stupify is both the quintessential spell
that one might use to stun
and one of the signature spells of the
good guys a well-positioned stupefy
could have done just what petrificus
totalis would have done
stopping her heart and ending her life
however
there's always the possibility that
molly simply used a spell that we don't
know about
in the harry potter universe there are
probably thousands hundreds of thousands
millions of spells that have been
introduced since the dawn of magic
and are willing to bet the most modern
day witches and wizards and they know a
fraction of them
there's a whole restricted section in
the hogwarts library filled with books
on magic
that witches and wizards aren't supposed
to touch and if we go by this scene in
the film
where bellatrix was defeated it's
clearly quite powerful magic
she basically freezes and then blows up
it's like a patrifica's totalis and a
bombarded maxima
all in one but whether there's a one
spell solution for this result or not
is anyone's guess in fact if we look at
her death in the film
and i know that the book is a much
better way to dissect this scene
she actually does use two spells a white
spell that could very well be petrificus
totalis
and then a red spell which could very
well be bombarded or perhaps even
reducto
what we have to remember about molly
weasley is that before she was molly
weasley
carrying mother figure she was molly
pruitt a witch that came from a long
line of powerful witches and wizards i'm
more than willing to bet that mrs
weasley is a lot more than meets the eye
and just because she's unassuming it
doesn't mean that she doesn't know
a lot of powerful magic after all molly
weasley
destroyed bellatrix to strange and
that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to support the
channel
what spell do you think molly used let
me know in the comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you